Wardrobe that was too outlandish for Prince,
communicating in a secret language, and a
cameo from a "90210" icon.
There's a lot to process with Luc Besson's
cult classic, "The Fifth Element," so forgive
yourself for not noticing a few things on
your first viewing.
"The Fifth Element" has a truly star-studded
cast.
It's not every day you see people like Bruce
Willis, Milla Jovovich, Ian Holm, and Gary
Oldman all sharing the screen.
Even the movie's smaller characters are played
by excellent actors like Brion James and Tom
Lister Jr. — and then of course there's
Chris Tucker's character, Ruby Rhod.
The first time you watch the movie, it's easy
to be so starstruck that you actually miss
one or two big stars who get featured.
On a second pass, though, you'll notice that
even extremely minor characters are played
by recognizable actors.
There's a reason, for instance, why Billy
looks so familiar in the beginning of the
movie.
Billy is a research assistant who witnesses
aliens landing on Earth in 1914.
He's got a very small part to play in the
movie, which is a little strange considering
he's played by Luke Perry.
By 1997, Perry was an established star, with
seven years of "Beverly Hills 90210" and plenty
of other roles under his belt.
Perry is the kind of actor who regularly showed
up in unexpected places, but even when he
doesn't have that much to do in a movie, he
brings a certain level of charm to a character.
At its heart, "The Fifth Element" is an adventure
story.
Korben's chance encounter with Leeloo sends
his life spiraling in a new direction, and
the two of them end up racing across deep
space to save the universe from evil.
The movie introduces some dazzling locations
and sci-fi concepts, but it doesn't spend
nearly as much time developing them as it
does rushing through the plot.
That's why every time you rewatch the movie,
you'll notice new small details about the
world — and sometimes they're a little concerning.
By the end of the movie, we don't know all
that much about New York City circa 2263,
but we've gotten enough details to learn that
the city is a borderline dystopia.
Korben's life as a taxi driver gives us a
glimpse into the capitalist nightmare that
seems to have taken over this version of the
future, and his chase with the police lets
us know that New York really needs to consider
some drastic reform measures.
As Korben's taxi races past a police hover
car early in the movie, we see that the NYPD
of 2263 wears full metal body armor at all
times, even if they're at a fast food drive-thru.
When the police start to pursue Korben, it
quickly becomes clear that collateral damage
isn't a concern for them.
They all but tear apart the city trying to
get Korben, and they don't even succeed.
When Leeloo lands in the back of Korben's
taxi, she doesn't know where she is, and she
definitely doesn't know how to speak English.
"Boom."
"Boom, yeah, I understand boom."
Considering that she's just been essentially
resurrected and brought into the future from
thousands of years in the past, she learns
how to communicate remarkably quickly.
Though she picks up more and more English
as the movie progresses, most of the time
Leeloo speaks a language beyond anyone's comprehension.
In reality, the words that Leeloo speaks were
created by director Luc Besson just for this
movie.
Besson spent 15 years developing the world
of "The Fifth Element," and in all that time
he also spent some effort creating a dictionary
for the Divine Language.
Besson invented around 400 words so that Leeloo
could, in theory, say everything she needs
to say through the entire movie in a real
language.
Besson and Milla Jovovich both became so fluent
in the Divine Language that they even used
it to communicate with each other while filming.
"The Fifth Element" gets more mileage than
most movies out of playing with tropes and
character archetypes.
The story has a traditional big evil and a
chosen one destined to defeat it.
Leeloo and Korben both get to play out different
takes on the hero archetype, while Gary Oldman's
Zorg stands in for the movie's real villain.
The movie sets up a story that's initially
familiar, but it subverts the usual formula
whenever it can.
One of the oddest parts about "The Fifth Element"
is that the heroes and the villains never
actually see each other face to face.
Obviously the big space evil is a kind of
amorphous entity that would probably have
trouble standing on the surface of Earth,
but Korben never even meets Zorg, the evil's
human representative, while Leeloo only runs
into him briefly.
But that doesn't mean they have no connection
to him whatsoever.
The first time they watch the movie, most
people probably miss a small detail on Korben's
termination notice after he loses his job.
Zorg owns the company that fires Korben, so
even though the two never directly meet, their
conflict is still personal.
According to "The Fifth Element," by 2263
humanity will have spread out to the stars
and made contact with alien civilizations.
The future looks and sounds amazing, but when
you really think about the people who are
in charge of the planet, you might have second
thoughts about that.
"My philosophy Mr. President is shoot first
and ask questions later.
I don't like uninvited guests."
Earth's military has a big role to play in
"The Fifth Element."
They're the ones who make first contact with
the great evil that employs Zorg, and they
eventually help send Korben and Leeloo on
their journey to save the world.
It might be fair to say all's well that ends
well, but the movie shows us over and over
again how incompetent the future leadership
of Earth really is.
The President, played by Tom "Tiny" Lister
Jr., never seems to have any idea what's really
going on.
He's willing to take advice from Ian Holm's
Cornelius, despite having very little evidence
that the priest knows what he's talking about
when it comes to epic space evils.
The military, on the other hand, is represented
by Brion James' character General Munro.
You'd want a general to have a sound tactical
mind, but Korben manages to outsmart Munro,
leaving him trapped in a freezer in his apartment
while he escapes with Leeloo.
The movie is definitely saying something about
people in power, but it's also depicting a
future we'd all be better off avoiding.
"The Fifth Element" is filled with great performances,
but Chris Tucker's appearance as Ruby Rhod
is one of the most memorable parts of the
entire movie.
From clothing to hair, Ruby's sense of style
is something that you won't forget after seeing
it.
Tucker brings a tremendous amount of energy
to the role, helping Ruby steal scenes so
thoroughly that even the characters in the
movie seem to be a bit stunned by Tucker's
performance.
It turns out that everyone on set probably
was just as surprised by Tucker as anyone
who's ever watched "The Fifth Element."
Tucker told EW that when he took the part,
hardly anyone knew what the role was supposed
to be, including himself.
All he knew was that Prince was supposed to
play the role, but he passed it up because
the costumes were too outlandish.
Tucker didn't know what to think, until he
saw the costume for himself.
He said -
"I was kind of like 'Whoof, this is a deep,
deep character.'
But all that stuff really helped me get into
character."
Gary Oldman is one of the greatest character
actors of his generation.
He's played some heroic characters, but Oldman
really shines as a villain.
Whether he's playing a shapeshifting vampire
in "Bram Stoker's Dracula" or the crazed mayor
of a post-apocalyptic town in "The Book of
Eli," Oldman brings a chilling energy to all
his baddies.
Amidst all the aliens and shiny scenery, it
can be easy to lose track of Oldman's character
Zorg in "The Fifth Element," but the second
time through you'll realize how terrifying
he really is.
What makes Zorg so scary isn't that he's working
for a terrible evil, but that communicating
with his evil boss seems to shake Zorg to
his very core.
On the phone with the evil entity, Zorg's
head spontaneously starts bleeding, and his
own terror is very apparent.
Despite his fear, he keeps trying to help
the evil grow in power.
Oldman's performance in the movie is even
more impressive if you know the context surrounding
it.
In an interview with Role Recall, the actor
admitted that he only took the role as a favor
to Luc Besson.
He didn't even read the script before agreeing
to be in the movie, and it doesn't sound like
he's a huge fan of the finished product.
When told that "The Fifth Element" has become
a cult classic, Oldman just laughed and said
-
"That's the wacky world we live in."
As a character, Leeloo is obviously based
on "chosen one" tropes that are as old as
time itself.
The movie repeatedly says that she's supposed
to be a perfect being.
It's not just that Leeloo is destined to save
the world, but also that she has some borderline
magical abilities.
She's an incredibly fast learner, and all
but a champion fighter with little to no training
whatsoever.
Korben plays a central role in the story,
but it's really Leeloo who's the hero of "The
Fifth Element."
As much as she's based on mythological heroes
from stories that came before her, Leeloo
has also gone on to inspire other sci-fi heroes.
Her influence can easily be seen in characters
like River from "Firefly" and "Serenity,"
but she has a very particular similarity with
another major '90s sci-fi "chosen one."
In the movie Leeloo learns how to fight by
watching video feeds on a small screen.
She basically downloads the knowledge into
her head.
Two years after the debut of "The Fifth Element,"
Neo learns his own fighting techniques using
a very similar method in "The Matrix."
"I know kung fu."
There are plenty of '90s sci-fi movies that
don't hold up visually today.
CGI has come a long way in the past three
decades, and movies that went all in on the
technology back then are really starting to
show their age.
"The Fifth Element" has no shortage of special
effects, but the movie still looks fantastic
today because so much of what happens on screen
was created practically.
Luc Besson knew that his movie was going to
demand an excessive amount of visual effects
— it took more than 160 people to create
the 220 shots that made it into the movie,
and the team filmed plenty more that didn't
survive the editing room.
Besson employed model makers and artists to
make his world as realistic as possible.
The spaceships shown in the movie are real
models.
So is Korben's taxi, and even some of the
New York City streets that he flies it down.
A second viewing gives one plenty of time
to really appreciate the level of effort that
went into making "The Fifth Element" as visually
engaging as it is.
Unfortunately, not everything that you notice
about "The Fifth Element" when watching it
again is good.
There are plenty of things to praise about
the movie, from the performances to the music
to the visual effects, but decades later it
also stands out for being filled to the brim
with misogynist stereotypes.
There's no way around it: "The Fifth Element"
does a terrible job depicting women.
Leeloo is basically the only human woman on
screen the entire movie, and even though she's
a hardcore action hero, she still ends up
falling into the damsel in distress role more
than once.
As badass as Leeloo may be on her own, the
movie doesn't let her be a hero without the
help of Korben.
"But she's more fragile than she seems.
She needs your help… and your love."
She's also wearing little more than some strategically
placed bandages for the first third of the
film.
It's the other women in the movie that get
a really problematic portrayal.
Korben's mother and ex-wife, heard only as
voices talking to Korben over the phone, are
depicted as greedy nags who won't let Korben
live his life in peace.
The movie plays these moments for laughs as
Korben rolls his eyes and desperately tries
to avoid interacting with them as much as
possible.
Those cringe-worthy moments don't ruin the
film by any means, but they may tarnish your
memories of it on that second viewing.